what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Annihilation Conquest now
in the last video we talked about how
blast star of course being for the
Negative Zone had basically been
captured by the forces of the Phalanx a
lot of this is because at this point in
time with the Phalanx having captured
the cree Homeworld one of their main
focuses is to basically find these
different Insurgency cells right because
the reality is that even though Halla
has fallen there are still people who
have not been captured by the Phalanx
and who are still fighting back and so
trying to find these different locations
is Paramount but with blastar being so
capable one of the things that he had
previously established in the last video
is that when it comes to a successful
Insurgency you cannot have one person
that knows everything because if that
person's captured the whole Insurgency
can fall and so the reality is that
everything is effectively
compartmentalized right everything's
sort of moved into little sections and
so on and so forth where not everybody
has the pieces of the puzzle but with
blastar being so powerful being so
capable and him more or less kind of
being a general of sorts or at least in
some capacity a leader of the Insurgency
he has more information than most and so
what the Phalanx are doing are quite
literally forcing information out of
this guy the reality here though is that
at the end of the day blastar's not
dumping any information so while he does
succumb to this entire process and
basically dies then what we end up doing
here is switching over to the high
evolutionary now we will revisit blastar
here in a little bit because there is
more going on than were initially led to
believe but with the high evolutionary
here of course there's this kind of
conversation that goes on now one of the
things to know about Herbert Wyndham is
this guy does not suffer fools and he
does not like people who just don't know
what's going on so really like philavel
showing up here and saying she was
basically sent by the voice of the
Supreme intelligence to grab Adam
Warlock and bring him to this location
or at least Adam Warlock brought them
here anyway that she doesn't fully
understand what's going on which is to
say why it was that she was doing what
she was supposed to do she was just told
to do that and it pisses off the high
evolutionary because it just annoys him
like from his perspective he's one of
these guys where in a lot of ways he's
an extreme narcissist but also
rightfully so when you're a person with
an exceedingly high level of
intelligence there is truth to the
statement you're better than the people
around you so coming across a person
who's just like I mean I'm here but I
don't really know why I'm here a voice
told me to come here it really is him
just getting frustrated but the other
part of that and what keeps those
individuals under a normal circumstance
from just becoming exceedingly arrogant
and exceedingly full of narcissism is
empathy and understanding and just kind
of being like okay look so I get I get
like you're just you're following orders
right you're just doing what you're told
and that's it right like you're told
that like some kind of being out there
could save everybody or whatever but the
response here and really the idea is the
high evolutionary coming to this
realization that one Adam Warlock has
been woken up early but two his body's
developing new powers things that he
wasn't that he wasn't capable of doing
before and so because of all this
because of the fact that this all
happened too early again instead of him
emerging as his more controlled self and
instead of him emerging understanding
what his new powers are which is what he
would normally do he would literally
come out of his cocoon and be like I can
do new things cool right instead it's
just everything kind of running amok
that their stance is okay we have to
find a way to get these different
abilities under control we have to find
a way to get you back to your normal
place at least analyze you and
understand what's going on on a greater
scale now the other part of this is
switching over to the forces of Ron and
the accuser and those individuals who
have basically survived or at least
trying to Marshal some forces or gather
some forces that can help Stave off the
Fey length themselves and so as you have
Ron and the accuser and his forces
making their way across the world they
end up coming across what's left of the
annihilation wave that are basically
facing off against the forces of the
Phalanx now that's one of the things
that I do want to establish that in a
lot of ways annihilus was defeated his
campaign was ended that kind of thing
but the truth about it is that there was
also a kind of ceasefire that was given
and a portion of holla was handed over
to uh to a segment of the annihilation
wave it was done grudgingly and it
wasn't really done willingly but it was
done nonetheless but the other thing to
understand is the forces of the
annihilation wave under normal
circumstances are very very oppressive
right they're immensely capable but the
reality here is the annihilation wave is
more capable just based on sheer numbers
than it is on the individual powers of
the person that you're facing off
against so say for example you were
fighting against somebody like Jamie
Madrox the multiple man right like he's
just a guy who can duplicate himself
he's not very capable he's not
exceedingly strong he doesn't really
have super strength so in a one-on-one
fight somebody like Captain America
could easily subdue him but if Jimmy
Madrox created a thousand duplicates of
himself and they all attacked Captain
America they would get the upper hand on
him and that's really what it is when it
comes to the annihilation wave they kind
of rely on attrition more so than
anything else right just endless waves
that ultimately overtake the force
they're fighting against because that
Force just can't keep fighting forever
and so while you do have the
annihilation wave that's able to hold
its own to a degree the forces of the
Fey links are almost equally endless
right and they're exceedingly capable
but in the middle of all this Ronan and
all his forces are basically discovered
and so in facing off against the Phalanx
it turns into the enemy of my enemy is
my friend so the annihilation wave
realizing that Ronan is facing off
against the Phalanx they ultimately draw
a temporary ceasefire under any normal
circumstance because the cree are here
and basically encroaching on territory
that belongs to the annihilation wave it
would mean War right that was one of the
the aspects of the treaty that was
signed but because things are so dire
again affiliations and alliances are
being made that wouldn't normally be
made so the response of ronin is I am
called one of the accuser yes I stand
against the Phalanx take me to your
leader right take me to the one that's
that's in charge of your forces we will
form a coalition and we will work
together using our resources along with
your resources and we will defeat the
Phalanx because at the end of the day
sure we don't necessarily agree on
everything but like we do agree on the
fact that we want to live right and so
long as the fan lights are here that's
going to be hard to do so what we end up
doing here is we switch over to Peter
Quill now again Peter Quill was
basically at the beginning of the story
one of the things to remember is that
because holla is quite literally on
lockdown those individuals who were not
on the world when the failings took over
they're out of the picture they're out
there somewhere right and it's very
difficult for them or it's actually
impossible for them to enter the planet
Apollo itself those people who were here
can't get out so no one enters and no
one leaves that's the kind of
circumstance that you're looking at here
so the best you can really do when
you're someone like Peter Quill is form
a team that can help defeat these things
or take these things up and so what you
end up getting is the Guardians of the
Galaxy now one thing that I do want to
establish here this takes place before
the official formation of the team so
when it comes to the coming together of
the Guardians of the Galaxy it wasn't
really a One-Shot comic right it wasn't
really like Marvel coming along and
saying and now we present the Guardians
of the Galaxy a team you've never heard
of before but they exist now because
reasons the reality here is the
Guardians of the Galaxy came together
one part due to the original
Annihilation event but it was really
more of an idea that was being mulled
around in the head of Peter Quill just
because of the significance of the
annihilation event but then this event
here Annihilation Conquest this is kind
of the hammer in the nail right this is
the the point where he's like okay this
is a team that needs to exist the
characters that you see here rocker
raccoon Groot mantis and so on it's
really more that he kind of unified them
under everything that was going on but
they don't officially have a designation
yet they're not officially a team they
are but they aren't right but the
reality here and one of the things that
they had done is that working as part of
this Insurgency on Hala they had
actually had some of group spores
contained within blastar so while
blastar did end up dying when he did die
those spores basically emanated
throughout the entirety of the Babel
Spire that belongs to the Phalanx and
what ended up happening is it basically
created a kind of 3D map so where
literally you have man is that kind of
conjures this map by tapping into the
mind of Groot and basically shows them
exactly what the Spire looks like on the
inside it's effectively a heist mission
is really what this is that's kind of
this this idea going down it's like okay
what we're going to do is we're going to
get in there and we're going to blow
this fire up now as you normally expect
when it comes to uh when it comes to the
the Guardians of the Galaxy even in the
early formations of the team no one
really takes Peter Quill seriously even
here they don't right like Rocket
Raccoon kind of being the Weapon
Specialist is like okay so like are we
gonna blow this place up and the
response of Peter is like yes you bloody
well are like we're blowing this whole
place to Pieces right like are you guys
ready as far as I know no one else is
waging this war it's up to us are you
fighting fit are you badass shruggers
ready to kick some Phalanx butt and save
the universe and they're all just kind
of like
I mean dude you know like
I mean they want to they want to fight
but they want to fight like they want to
save the save the world right they want
to save holla and all that kind of stuff
but it's like Peter Quill like trying to
amp them up with like a super exciting
speech and it just kind of Falls flat
it's just it's cool right but this is
where the Guardians of the Galaxy start
this is how the team basically begins to
form but jumping back to the high
evolutionary and back to uh back to Adam
Warlock the high evolutionary kind of
spills the beams on why he's even
increased face in the first place and
what he says is he was actually brought
here or asked to come here by the
Supreme intelligence for the purpose of
basically modifying or adjusting the
evolution of the cree race now this has
kind of been a major focal point of the
Supreme intelligence for some time in
Marvel Comics and this really goes all
the way back to a story called Galactic
storm and it actually goes back further
than that so back in 1987 Chris
Claremont and Alan Davis wrote this
story in X-Men Annual issue number 11
that introduced something called the
crystal of ultimate vision and the way
this thing worked is that those
individuals who were able to attain the
crystal would basically gain absolute
power but there was a caveat here the
only people who could attain the Crystal
and actually use it were the ones who
never really wanted it in the first
place so which really better the
question why the hell does this thing
even exist but the thing behind this is
that it drew the attention of the
Supreme intelligence and so what it did
is that in a desire to basically Elevate
the cree and turn them into a race that
could effectively conquer the universe
it sent an emissary to use or to seize
the crystal of ultimate Vision the price
to be paid for those individuals who
seized the crystal with the intention of
using it is that it freezes their entire
race in terms of evolution right so like
they don't evolve any further and so the
result of this is that in a story called
operation Galactic storm the Supreme
intelligence initiated a war with the
Shia race this involved The Avengers and
so on and so forth there was a great big
huge 19 issue crossover it was a huge
story when it happened and it was pretty
significant it was one of those
landscape changing stories but the
overall reason why this even happened in
the first place is because the Supreme
intelligence knew that if it pushed the
Shia race far enough it would detonate
its ultimate bomb right this bomb that
basically could eradicate an entire star
system when that happened it basically
destroyed avoid something like 99 of the
cree race but that was a decision that
Supreme intelligence went with because
it believed it would force the evolution
of the Crete which it did right it
forced them out of the evolutionary
stagnation that came with trying to
seize the crystal of ultimate Vision now
one of the things that happened as a
result of this is you basically you
didn't really have a kind of Civil War
among the Korea but you had like the
pink cree and you had the blue Cree but
they weren't really a unified race and
so as time progressed they began to
unify but the truth is that the cree you
know being the race that it was had long
since been gone meaning that it was like
this race that was capable of just
conquering whole universes and things
like that and the reality is that the
Supreme intelligence believed that it
had basically just become too weak of a
race right like the wars that it fought
it constantly lost so on and so forth
and so the desire of the Supreme
intelligence was to meet with the high
evolutionary and had the high
evolutionary basically evolve or create
a new Cree race that could basically
become a replacement for either existing
Cree or at least begin to interbreed
with the existing cree and then just
kind of move them into another state of
evolution right where they would just
become more capable now what ended up
happening is that during the events of
annihilation the Supreme intelligence
went missing right it was basically gone
the result of this is that the high
evolutionary kept working on its own and
eventually he succeeded in this he
ultimately succeeded in creating a
perfect cree and so what he does is kind
of present this situation to Adam
Warlock and to Phila Vel and so on and
so forth but before they can really go
any further with any of this stuff the
high evolutionary tries to make a
bargain and simply saying that like it
doesn't really want to stay here anymore
because of the fact that even it can be
overtaken or even he can be overtaken by
the Phalanx and so his response is if
you give me safe passage out of cree's
space I will give you your evolved Cree
Warriors but of course there's no way in
or out of Cree space it's literally out
of phase with the rest of the universe
so it's almost like what the phalanes
did is they cut the entire of crease
space out of the universe and put it
somewhere else you can't go anywhere
right like if you were to try to keep
going far enough you would you know
inevitably run into a kind of wall right
so like there'd be nowhere for you to go
and the result of this is that they're
all effectively stuck there but then in
the middle of that you basically get the
forces of the Phalanx that teleport
directly to the high evolutionary in
Adam Warlock which are led by Ultron of
course again he himself saying he wanted
to take a more Hands-On approach the
first thing he does is he kills moon
dragon right off the bat literally
punches a hole in her chest and kills
her on the spot the next thing he says
is Adam Warlock you're the person I've
been searching for right you are the one
that I seek and the response of Adam
Warlock is okay that's cool man but
understand if you're coming for me
Ultron you're not gonna like what you're
gonna find but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all in the next video
peace